working actually with startups with
entrepreneurs
with new technologies both internally
and externally to actually
you know reinvent this industry and
bring it to the next stage uh that will
be healthier more sustainable and even
more fulfilling for consumers is super
exciting
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serrano partners and in media
partnership with ctek
if you like food or snacks or both this
episode is just for you
meet gil horsky
gil's passion is investing in and
building new snacking and food tech
ventures that are good for people
kind to the planet and deliciously fun
gil is part of the snack features
founding team the ventures and
innovation hub from mondelez
international the largest snacking
company in the world gill is the senior
director of venture investments and
bundles leading the company's global
venture investments in food tech supply
chain and digital capabilities
prior to joining mandalas gil worked for
pepsico in the us and throughout his
career porsche had the privilege to work
on some of the most iconic global brands
like milka pepsi quaker oats toblerone
cadbury oreo tropicana and nestle purina
and levered strong business and consumer
insights
meet gil
[Music]
you have such a phenomenal background
working with some of the most incredible
organizations after doing your your
bachelor's of arts and political science
in tel aviv university and then getting
your mba at kellogg and then
transitioning to be doing als working at
pepsico and tour food tech and nestle
and today mandela is looking at snack
futures and the future of snacks so gil
thank you so much for joining me today
i'm really excited
i'm super excited as well and uh you're
right you know i think it's super
exciting to talk about the future of
food and snacking and there's so much
going on in general in this space in the
last years and especially in israel so
yeah happy to share more
well so you know i first i want to
understand you know how
what is the future of food and how
should we begin asking ourselves a
question you know really a research
question
what does the future of food hold for us
how do we even approach
a complicated question like that
sure so i think you know the interesting
thing is you know the food and ag
industry is one of the biggest
industries in the world it's an eight
trillion dollar industry you know from
growing seeds to shelf into what we eat
on our our tables at home
and um you know the world of food and
snacking is
definitely changing i mean we um
you know the way we're eating today and
what we're eating today is very
different than what we ate a few years
ago and i think you know some of the
changes we're seeing first of all is you
know we all grew up i'm sure you the
same with eating three meals a day and
today we're eating probably something
like an average seven mini meals per day
we're all on the go we don't have time
anymore to cook and to eat three stable
meals with our family we're on the go
we're looking for the different
nutrition we need we have different
needs throughout the day we might need
something with energy in the morning we
might need something it gives us another
energy in the afternoon we might need
something before we go to sleep to fall
asleep we want might want something like
an indulgence in the evening or snack
with family and friends in front of tv
and i think all these behaviors
are really changing the the industry
and um of course the you know the last
hundred years have moved the food
industry to become much more
industrialized and it's much more scale
and that's companies like ours and um
you know i know you mentioned uh
obviously mondelez mod at least is the
largest snacking company in the world so
we are the biggest chocolate company in
the world with brands such as milka
oberon and cadbury and the largest um
biscuit company with oreo and velveeta
and hopefully uh mikhail you eat a lot
of our products if not i'll make sure to
send you a few home after this interview
um but
basically now actually you're seeing a
lot of trends of consumers going back
to the pre-industrialization phase
people are looking especially by the way
covey change a lot of things people are
suddenly looking for for locally grown
food you start having the the concept of
vertical farming or urban farming or
even people just growing vegetables and
fruits um in their houses gardens etc
the second thing you're seeing is the
need of personalization people are
suddenly saying you know what each of us
has different needs
you might be a diabetic somebody might
else might be you need to is a vegan or
gluten-free etc or even different tastes
so the industry is changing with with
some of those needs of course and then i
think one of the biggest changes is of
course around sustainability and
circular economy consumers are much more
concerned how is their food grown is it
in a sustainable way is the packaging
sustainable and recyclable and all these
things are actually
a very fertile ground for a lot of
innovation a lot of new startups a lot
of big companies like ours that are
needing to reinvent themselves uh the
whole time which i think what is what
makes the food industry so exciting
today
so we're we're in the beginning of 2022
obviously i believe that the shelves
that we're seeing on the supermarket are
vastly different than the way that they
looked you know even 10 years ago and
the rate of change of the shelves and
the ability for for small brands to pop
up and allow themselves to reinvent
themselves or for large companies and
i'm sure that a lot of the brands that i
see on the shelf are actually mandalas
but how what what is what is you know
the opportunity today for reinvention in
the world of food like what is new to
2022 that we didn't have 100 years ago
that allows us to do this rapid
invention invention and innovation
so there's a lot of things that are
actually enabling to do reinvention you
know if you look until 10 years ago
you know there was only one route to
market you could sell its stores let's
talk about the us or in israel israel
it's super sunny this might be whole
foods walmart you know whatever that is
costco sam's you were only able to sell
at retail mainly
the big companies like ours were players
in retail um what has changed is
suddenly the retail environment started
changing first of all e-commerce came
direct to consumer amazon guess what
when you're a small brand you actually
can succeed as much as a big brand
in in the online online space too a lot
of retailers were looking for smaller
brands some retailers such as costco sam
whole foods uh starbucks in the u.s
we're much more looking for giving this
experiential
experience for consumers with new unique
brands and consumers who are looking for
them
and i think that enabled um a lot of
change in the industry because a lot of
the new smaller brands have brought a
lot of change and when you're asking um
about what we're expecting in the future
um or you know what is up in 22 20 22 is
you know a few things i mean plant-based
is big so consumers are looking to you
know eat less meat or eat meat that is
not coming from an animal uh both from
an environmental perspective and also
from an ethical perspective the same is
with milk the same is with seafood we're
seeing these waves i think that's one
thing the second thing is which i'm very
excited is the space of food as medicine
is actually the notion
of
can food become a great carrier
for prevention of health for you as a
consumer meaning can you actually
instead of taking pills instead of
eating powders can your snacks or food
have a functional benefit that can be as
effective as some of those but it's in a
form that is tasty and we're seeing some
interesting ingredients such as
functional mushrooms moving into that
space that we were looking at uh or
nootropics or others so those are some
of the interesting spaces and i would
ask i would just add also you know you
asked earlier how
how did basically how is the industry
changing um for smaller brands that's
one of the reasons why we created snack
futures so snack futures is not about
just claiming what's the future
actually we do three things we manage
the company's corporate venture arms so
we make investments in early stage
startups both on the brand side and also
on the food tech and capability side and
we invested
in israel
at a company called tour food tech that
actually enables you to actually weld
together ingredients into snacks without
the sugary binder
that's one thing we do the second thing
we actually incubate new businesses so
for example we're big believers in the
space of vegetables again as i said
earlier people are eating less meals a
day they're eating mini meals
historically vegetables were eaten in
meals
so consumers are eating less vegetables
but they're looking to get a vegetable
in a snack form if you think about it a
fruit a banana or an apple you can eat
on the go but you would never see
somebody down the street in diesengoff
walking with a tomato or a cucumber the
only vegetable that is snackable is
maybe a carrot so we actually incubate
new businesses like entrepreneurs
we go we do it separately from the
company because our company is you know
it's a 30 billion dollar sales company
almost 100 billion dollar market cap we
are built for scale so we would actually
go aside and like an entrepreneur work
with an outside r d team with an outside
coat packers with an outside distributor
an incubated brand and one of those we
did in vegetables is called snacks it's
called dirt kitchen
and we go we test it usually in lay in
one market several stores we see how it
does and if it does well we scale it up
so
those are some of the things we're doing
so in a way we're taking some of the
things from the playbook of
entrepreneurs and putting them in a big
company setting
does technology play any role in in what
you're describing here so obviously you
know there's the the go-to-market
strategy and a b testing and being able
to to leverage technology to create the
actual product but what can we leverage
today in 2022 in terms of you know the
technology around us social media
different tracking mechanisms to even
understand whether the product we're
putting on the store works besides the
fact how much is being sold from the
shelf
technology plays a huge role in the
industry again as i said it's an 8
trillion dollar industry end to end and
actually there's the mckinsey study that
was done a few years ago about the some
of the largest industries in the world
and their level of digitization and food
and ag was one of the lowest ones so
technology plays
a role even from you know just
manufacturing iot big data
industry 4.0 and for sure to your
question in the space of market research
in the past we had to wait sometimes
weeks and months to get insights from
consumers online today
in the physical world we would you know
when i started off in pepsi i still
remember we would go to a shopping mall
and we would stop consumers and let them
taste it and wait for all the data today
you can actually do things very quickly
we can put different concepts on
facebook instagram we call it instapops
we wait to get consumers to see if they
click through and from there we see what
concept's interesting there's not even a
product yet but we're just seeing the
engagement level the interest level the
same is today you have the ability to do
focus groups online to talk with
consumers online we talk with consumers
in their homes
we sometimes send them products and they
actually use their phone with a whatsapp
and actually every day would send our
market research team insights and when
they're using the product pictures
videos so today we are able to get
insights
you know on a daily basis if we need uh
versus in the past you have to wait
weeks and months and the same is by the
way for social media if you want to mine
trends and look at what's what is spoken
on social media um what are the trends
we can go we can zoom down to the level
of seeing you know what's happening in
new york state or new york city what are
consumers looking for even in a certain
neighborhood um from an ingredient
perspective a food perspective a dish
perspective a brand perspective so
obviously it gives you a lot of power i
think the bigger
challenge is actually distilling your
insights and actions from all that
insights today we have so much data in
learnings and insights so distilling
these for something actionable that's
probably the harder part today
so they what i'm hearing here is that it
then it's it and it then all comes down
to the actionability now what are we
seeing in terms of
micro brands versus the larger brands
that that you know in terms of also
trust and and consumer behavior
surrounding that because it's before i
was only you know contemplating
purchasing a certain brand of for
example dairy in the supermarket now it
seems that i'm much more compliant to
try different brands and even get
excited
when there's a new young and exciting
brand that is showing its face on the
shelf what's happening with consumer
behavior there
right so i mean i think what you're
seeing as i mentioned before i think in
the last 10 years you're seeing that 10
years ago you would not see emerging
brands because they didn't even have
where to be sold
today they have and there are a lot of
them are have a strong founder story it
can be a female or a male or even we see
teenagers with a strong story why they
created it with a strong mission and
they would usually start creating a
tribe around them a tribe of followers
and believers and slowly scale up and
some of the biggest brands you see today
maybe ten five years ago have started is
a small is a small kind of more micro
brand
i think what we do in snack futures we
try to either invest in some of those
that are in the well-being snacking
space or even build our own
but i would definitely say that being a
micro brand today um there's much more
openness both from a retailer in a
consumer perspective to try new things
um obviously there's still the
fundamentals you know
you have to be a great tasting product i
mean at the end of the day food is about
day so you can have the sexiest
marketing in packaging and and solve all
these nutritional benefits if the thing
is not tasty and you won't have repeat
the brand would just won't go anywhere
and i think you still need patience
building a brand and i think that's the
beauty and the challenge in this
industry we are talking about physical
products it's very different than some
of the tech we know in some of the
companies you interview with some of
your other um sessions which you know is
maybe a fintech product or a cyber that
can just go and scale within you know a
night and become very very big here it's
still real world you manufacture you
distribute you sell slowly you scale up
you get into more stores more people buy
you so you need patience even if it
might even if you're a micro brand but
it's definitely a very interesting time
of both micro brands in big brands and i
think the way i view it from our
perspective when we have big brands
it just makes us better right because
we in the past our our playbook was
competing against other big brands we
all were using very similar strategies
and tactics we all came from the same
companies
today we actually need to compete with a
lot of smaller brands that are growing
very fast so i think you know and i'm
saying this in a positive way i think
when you're in a dynamic market and you
don't just have one or two competitors
you have actually 20
and they have different playbooks it
just makes you better so i i view it as
a positive thing and for the consumer
it's great because there's more choice
100 and obviously we can look at classic
examples like nokia and kodak and a lot
of different companies exactly that
really were were you know monopolies in
their field that were market leaders and
at the end what eventually brought to
their downfall in many cases and in many
verticals is there really the fact that
they didn't have a need really for
innovation and it wasn't very clear that
the market was demanding it and i think
that's just an awesome observation for
for how you're experiencing it within
within a large company if we're looking
you know years down the line at snacking
as a concept and snacking behavior
is this going to change at all or is do
we have just a fundamental idea okay we
as humans we eat meals and we enjoy
snacking and this is how we're going to
be you know for this is how we perceive
humanity moving forward
it's a beautiful question i think that
um
our belief and i think we have strong
conviction and i also have a strong
conviction again we're not fortune
tellers so time would say but um our
strong belief is
that snacking is a behavior it's just
going to get bigger so this trend of
consumers eating today you know on
average depends on the country etcetera
but you know one can play maybe you know
around five seven mini meals per day
would just get bigger because people are
more busy um people have gotten used to
these different needs throughout the day
et cetera and different products solving
different problems from consumers or
they're fulfilling their need throughout
the day i think the interesting part is
going to be
how are these snacks going to look in
the future how are they going to evolve
so today for example we're all used to a
snack bar how would a snack bar look
like in five years
or you're even seeing some concepts that
are blurring lines for example you have
a category which is actually meal
replacement it's basically beverages you
have several brands around the world are
doing it's a beverage that you drink it
and it actually gives you the same
nutrients and filling satiety feeling of
a meal and that's by the way a snack
also even a beverage can be snack if if
it's fulfilling and doing a need of a
snack and it's on the go it can serve as
a snack so i think we're going to see an
evolution of what are these product
forms
what needs they're fulfilling because
consumers are going to have different
needs and we all have different needs
throughout their lives as we age etc so
i think that's going to be the evolution
we see in the in the industry and the
second one is how do we actually get
these products i mean you know again i
don't want to be now looking super crazy
to the future but you know today we
still buy them online and the store i
mean maybe there's a day i don't think
it's in the near term but you know maybe
10 to 15 years down the road you're
gonna have a 3d printer and you're going
to press a button and you're going to
print all the snacks for the next day i
mean could be maybe not i don't know
it's hard to say um but i think we're
definitely going to see um an evolution
of of the needs and of the product forms
in the future um and obviously as
specific trends evolve for example
sustainability etc even more
responsibility around how we source
ingredients how the products are made
because i think the topic of
sustainability um in the impact that the
food industry has on the sustainability
um and you know climate and the
ecosystem in general is just going to
become a bigger topic and that's clear
what do you enjoy most about what you do
i see clearly you're so passionate about
this world and you have such an
incredible experience all around what do
you enjoy most about this work that you
do here
i mean i think you know first of all
there's not a bigger joy than fulfilling
needs of consumers and you know i mean
again we all think we do it but you know
i engage with consumers in a daily basis
listen i go to my kids school or i go to
a party and somebody starts telling me
what is their favorite milka or oreo
flavor and you know the amazing thing in
snacks especially in chocolate and
cookies and all these things people are
emotionally attached to them engage in
them listen there's a lot of research
that the first chocolate you ate as a
kid you think is the tastiest chocolate
i don't know which one you had but it's
a chocolate you grew up with and it's
the taste of your childhood and you have
a lot of memories with it so i think
it's a very emotionally engaging
industry and role and i think
specifically for me in my specific world
is working actually with startups with
entrepreneurs
with new technologies both internally
and externally to actually you know
reinvent this industry and bring it to
the next stage that will be healthier
more sustainable and even more
fulfilling for consumers is is super
exciting
i love it gil i really want to thank you
for your awesome
you know
outlook and excitement and understanding
and expertise i just love what you're
doing and it sounds so freaking cool and
i i really appreciate your time and your
energy and that's it just thank you and
stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]